Jordan's with us in Kansas hey Jordan
how are you good Dave how's it going
better than I deserve what's up I was
just wanting to ask you whether you
thought I should sell my vehicle based
on my current financial situation okay
what's the car worth the car is worth
about 10 10 to 11 depending on whether I
took it to a dealer salt private party
no I mean for on you know 1934 Oh
thirteen thirteen four and what do you
make all right
about 44 okay do you like the car it's
mostly my wife's car I commute probably
about 50 minutes so about 50 miles to
work currently I'm driving a paid off
Mustang good and I you we drive that to
work the reason we were thinking about
selling is because she only drives maybe
once or twice a week and I feel like
it's depreciating like a rock as you say
you know I was thinking about just
selling it taking the $3,000 or so hit
and then buy baby uh three four five
thousand dollar car somewhere in there
with cash
I don't you been married two years
okay good good and what's your household
income you told me forty something right
yeah 45 44 sorry well the rule of thumb
that we use is this we tell folks not to
own vehicles that total up more than
half your annual income yours don't okay
and we tell folks to be in a situation
where whatever debt you've got other
than your home you get it paid off
within two years you can unless there's
a whole bunch of that you didn't tell me
about here and the car is not keeping
you from doing it anyway so if I'm in
your situation
I'm keeping the car and I'm gonna work
really really hard to get it paid off
because there is a federal law that
sometimes they don't tell you when you
get married I learned it later in life
and I wish I had known it early federal
law is mama gets the good car if you
violate the law the relationship police
coming knocking not on your head and so
I would suggest that mama get
the good car and let's get that thing
paid off even if she's not driving in a
lot you're at work you're driving 50
miles she's got a dependable vehicle
therefore your young wife and your young
marriage and that's that you guys can
get paid off and keep if you told me the
car is 40 thousand a thousand 20 seconds
and if she wasn't whining about it I'd
call her a princess but that's not the
situation that's nothing that's going on
here this is you just trying to tighten
the screws down and you're being a good
man for looking at that but I'm just
gonna tell you I would because it's not
that big a number I would even ratio to
your other numbers I would keep it and
get it paid off as fast as I possibly
could